um good evening ladies and gentlemen
um welcome everyone to the overview and
scrutiny Committee of the 4th of October
2022.
before we start the meeting properly I
would like to read out the emergency
evacuation announcement
there are no planned fire drills so if
the alarm activates please leave the
building in an orderly fashion via your
nearest fire exit
the two fire exits through the partition
doors are currently not in use due to
ongoing Works therefore the fire exits
are through the main doors of the hall
or the storeroom adjacent to the stage
the farm assembly point is the
roundabout stroke island in the front of
the main entrance to this building
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
Council staff
please note that this meeting will be
audio recorded
would you please switch off your mobiles
or turn them to silent
and toilets and hand washing facilities
are available in the foyer area
members there's a need to use
microphones during this meeting when I
invite you to speak please wait until
there is a microphone in front of you
before speaking as the microphones are
needed for the hearing Loop and for the
audio recording
these are all switched on and are ready
for you to speak so you do not need to
adjust them
thank you
please make sure that the microphone is
directly in front of you when speaking
as it won't pick up your voice
and members voting will be done on a
show of hands in line with the
Constitution
I'll ask for a show of hands for and
then against recommendations and I'll
also ask for a show of hands for those
wishing to abstain from voting
so moving on to agenda item one which is
apologies for absence apologies have
been received for from councilor Richard
Lamborn and councilor John Mason
a gender item two substitute members
attending councilor Mrs Wilson welcome
a gender item three non-members
attending we've got councilor Simon
Wootton councilor Arthur Williams
councilor Mike Webb councilor Cheryl
Rowe councilor Daniel left day and
councilor Chris Stanley so welcome all
and I'd also like to welcome members of
the public as well
moving on to agenda item four which is
the minutes of the meeting held on the
8th of July 2022
are these minutes agreed members
okay thank you those are agreeing
agenda item five to receive Declarations
of Interest
are there any Declarations of Interest
members
okay there are none thank you
so we now move on to agenda item six
which is the one team transformation
program the Strategic partnership with
Brentwood Borough Council and it's a
quarter three update and I'll now ask
the council's director of policy and
delivery Greg Campbell to introduce the
report please Greg
is that correct thank you chair uh first
of all uh good evening members I'm Greg
Campbell director of policy and delivery
I think it's first time I've seen many
of you and probably the first time
you've seen me so just want to say hello
and I'm sure that we'll have
conversations in the near future and get
to know each other a bit better as time
moves forward
um just give an overview of the report
that we've got before of us because
there's a couple of updates to give that
you may be aware of already but
obviously the directors interviews that
were outstanding the five they've taken
place and two other directors have been
appointed Phoebe Barnes to add assets
and investment and Sarah Bennett to
customer and data Insight that leaves
outstanding a director needing to be
appointed to people and governance and a
director to resources the other director
at the moment for housing is actually an
interim contract at Julian hogson who's
uh undertaken that role at the present
time
um obviously we'll be going out in the
near future to re-employ to those
positions as soon as we can
what that leads me on to is obviously
how they're going to be looked after in
those positions in the near future so
there are discussions at the moment
happening to make sure that there is
that continuation of service at the
moment making sure that those voids are
filled and making sure that there is no
lapse in service as that happens so that
those conversations are going on
what this also leads to is the financial
position obviously this may impact the
bottom line at the very end and you'll
note that obviously where we're keeping
people on where we haven't employed it
may impact the financial position
towards the end and there may be a
slight cost pressure
I do not know exactly what that is at
the moment I've been talking to the
financial director and there will be an
update I believe in the next quarter
what I can say is obviously in the
report your note 4.2 says there is no
pressure obviously because of those
positions there will be a slight
pressure but what I can't do is actually
tell you what that is at this time
I would like to finish though just to
update you really on some of the
positives that we've been having been
having meetings with the key change
Champions with the managers of both
Brentwood and Rochford be moving them
and progressing that work over the last
couple of months and we're now ready to
bring together that road map and start
the service reviews at the end of this
month and therefore we'll be able to put
them through and then must start making
changes towards the end and the start of
the new year
that's my update for this evening chat
happy for obviously any questions thanks
great uh members anyone
have any questions for Greg
and the report
cancer Reeves
thank you just a couple of practical
things if I may um during the transition
one of the things that we're finding
very uh frustrating is the fact that we
are dealing with people who we don't
know
um a couple of practical suggestions on
that I know that the chairman has
offered to host a meeting for members to
attend and meet the new
members of the new offices of the
council I'd like to see that action if
possible please the other thing is while
we're going through this transition it
would help me in particular if when we
have a signature at the end of the
report that it's actually followed
underneath by the typed name because at
the moment we are not familiar with
who's who so I just see a street
signature there I've got no idea who it
is so just a couple of practical things
would be very helpful thank you Jim
like it
do you want to come back on that
absolutely as I said at the start I
would like to get to know all of you so
if that opportunity is there great
fantastic and if if something happens I
can make sure I'm available to meet you
at a point we can put that in the diary
and do that not a problem at all and
yeah
um it's just uh obviously as you point
out it would be good to have the name
under a signatory signatures aren't the
best sometimes at reading anyway so
definitely would be worth having it
printed take point taken thank you thank
you Council Mr Gooding
foreign
good evening Greg
um it might be me but if it is I
apologize
points uh 3.16
and 3.18
on reading through then they do appear
to perhaps contradict themselves are you
just able to clarify those two points
for us
3.16 and
3.18 was it yeah so the ICT this relates
to both the ICT so
3.16 is about ICT working with
Facilities Management HR across the
board identifying some of the more
practical issues that need to be sorted
very basic things that may fall outside
of service reviews a bit like
um key fobs to get into both areas ways
of working some of the more simplistic
but needed they could fall off the radar
if they're not picked up so that's a
piece of work that's happening there the
other part I think is more the ICT
review
yeah and that is more very much based in
what ICT are doing standardizing
equipment across both boards so that's
being picked up because it's purely an
I.T D thing but some of the other stuff
is more the practicalities that if we
don't keep an eye on I wouldn't say fall
through the text but it may just get
pushed but I want to make sure we
capture them early and therefore we make
sure that we deal with them as we move
along okay thank you okay thank you
councilor
Mr Newport even first
thank you chairman
um
good evening uh Greg and um
in this report it refers to the section
113.
um document that I made a request to the
CEO on the 15th of September to have a
copy sent to me which he then Julie
delegated to you to send to me which I
still haven't received
which leads me until question
regarding the ICT
in your opinion
does the team's Rochford and Brentwood
have the skill set in order to complete
this piece of work because I've been
waiting for a significant amount of time
for some basic Administration tasks to
be carried out by both teams and that
Administration task is simply to share a
calendar of the CEO and other directors
and we're still not at a point where
they can deliver that to me as an I.T
professional
performing that basic function the basic
Administration task
I find it very hard to believe
that we don't have the skills to
complete that
so is there a risk to the project
or the transformation
in the capabilities of your ICT team
thank you Council new Paul I'll take the
first part I apologize if I haven't
provided you with this 6113 I'll make
sure that happens as soon as I'm back in
the office tomorrow to organize that so
you can have that there's no problem
there I'm sorry about that with regard
the specific problem I don't know about
that right now so I can find out why
that has been a problem and you've said
you've been asking it for some time I'll
find out what the delay is and I'll come
back to you with regards to the teams
and I've met both ICT teams I'm
confident in their ability obviously
there are things that are going to come
up that will be challenging and it is
about how we meet those challenges head
on but the people that I have met and
worked with in the past from both groups
they give me confidence in what their
ability is it depends on some of the
challenges as we know we're looking at
merging Services together that will
throw up all sorts of challenges we may
need some different experts to bring
into the organization to deliver some of
those aspects of what that that merge
will bring teams together maybe but I'm
confident with when I've spoken to them
on their abilities but obviously once
we've done the service review of ICT and
what that needs to be moving forward
because it may be a different animal
there
can I just come back on that yeah I'm
just I'm sorry I'm just a bit concerned
in in the migration obviously you've got
a migration plan that those risks
haven't already been identified before
you get there as to whether you have got
a skill set in-house because as we well
know within Rochford Council certainly
we've been caught out by this before and
it's ended up costing the council a lot
of money and the chairman will actually
um verify that because we were both
um in a meeting about transformation
previously yeah so
I assume there is a project plan
and that transformation program for ICT
specifically
are those risks going to be identified
ahead are we just going to wait until we
stumble upon those problems and then say
Oh we can't do that we're going to need
a consultant and that's going to cost us
a lot of money
and I think that is to me what you're
telling me now that's where you're at
now and I think that you need to take a
step back and actually put together a
proper transformation plan for ICT
specifically
I'm am I so so yeah Scouts your new uh
new pool uh two things there
um I will look at the risk on the
resources I do know that ICT are I think
is mentioned in the report I believe are
looking at the risks at the start of
phase two and I'll make sure that that
is taken into account and make sure that
the resources are there and to
scrutinize that in terms of I suppose
you take it two ways one having the
skills that we have right now to deal
with what we know but of course when the
services start undertaking their reviews
there are some unknowns there about what
that may look like in the future and
therefore I can't answer all the
questions on the skills that we may need
in a few months or a year's time so we
can only work on what we know at the
moment and what's going out but as soon
as we're aware of those and as part of
the service review if there is going to
be a changing course in what the program
may be needed delivered or what the
platform is going to be used and we need
to get some experts in we will make sure
we bring that in and resolve
okay
sorry and
did I miss about transformation plan for
the ICT
yeah so there is we have a general
transformation plan then there's the
service reviews which we've got a road
map to have and part of that ICT is
included within that okay
okay thank you
um council Mrs Gadsden
good evening
um I've got a question around
3.8 and the s111 the sorry the S11 free
agreement on page 6.2
and I gather that's now complete the
work on that's complete I'd be quite
interested to know whether as the
committee will get to view that and
Gabby you're going to update the
Constitution and I'm wondering if we're
getting to see that before the
Constitution's update or will it be
afterwards
um the the 113 is now complete you can
have site of that one one three yes I'd
very much like that I think it probably
other members would as well and my
second question for you is around
um
how the improvements to the services
between the partnership will be measured
I'm not quite certain of the baselines
or do you have baselines in both
councils that you can use to measure
improvements for residents and how how
often will that be updated for the
Review Committee or of councilors to see
thank you so there are obviously sorry
sorry the 113 I through you I'll make
sure that can circulate it to your
members
um with regards uh the Baseline they're
already as we know you measure
performance so there are those baselines
already in place however moving forward
we start the service reviews it'd be
important that we do know what the
Baseline is that we're starting on so as
part of that work baselines are taken
and then we move forward on what those
are we'll then set what our objectives
are and there may be new performance
measures that we need to be put in place
but rest assured that the Baseline will
be taken into account when the original
service reviews are undertaken brilliant
thank you okay thank you councilor Mill
uh yeah thank you chairman um yeah my
question is really it's about risk
assessment and the engagement with the
committee because this is a complex set
of multiple work streams
and it has got
um
in our seven in the appendix
these two issues at the bottom there
which are lack of Engagement
understanding of the program
and another issue is impact of tier
three review posts so that is a that is
a
has a higher score now this reflects
actually this is a complex program of
many work streams so the engagement with
this committee my sort of question would
be
of the methodology really of the
overview in that we have a smart
objectives schedule so we can say what
we perceive the problem to be what's
been going on with it how's it going to
be resolved and where we're at because
otherwise this is quite a piece of work
with
and you know it's quite impressive
both sides you know dealt with it and
just to make sure we get it right and
there aren't any issues that slip by
like the ICT
and I know there's an awareness of this
but there's a resourcing issue with a
risk on it and there's an understanding
of the whole thing which has got a risk
issue with it so I'm just my question
really goes back to the chair do you see
it doing us doing it that way
um so as we see it through as it were
well throw it back to you cancer have
you got a recommendation that you yeah
well I recommend we we deal with it that
way because then we've you know we're
not going to miss anything are we we're
going to deal with it properly that's
all I'm saying okay if you can
do you want me to write write it up and
give you over on an email or something
yeah yeah okay yeah thanks that's it
okay thank you um councilor Mrs
McPherson
thank you chair
um it's with regard to paragraph 4.1 and
the temporary staff
um let's be honest temporary staff are
usually expensive you've already touched
that there is going to be a slight cost
pressure your concept of slight might be
different to how concept of slight so if
we could have some
um finances
um produced to demonstrate the cost
that's been incurred and on that have we
not looked at how existing staff and can
they be upskilled for these roles
so I I can't really comment on the
existing staff because I haven't been
involved in that process and the
upskilling of those staff
um what I can say is obviously we will
see sight of the finances and the
pressures every time we report back
anyway and I believe there is a budget
report coming back to uh Rochford
council at some point in the near future
anyway which will take account of the
pressure that's being put on there
um so it's difficult for me to say about
the staff that have gone through the
process and upskilling them from the
position that I sit at the moment I'm
sorry
thank you um chairman could I make a
recommendation that we do investigate
that as an option
possibly investigating if we can upskill
any existing staff
to be able to
apply for those roles
thank you chairman
thank you um
councilor constable
thank you chairman um it's on the cost
and scale of redundancies do we have any
idea of the cost and the scale of the
redundancies yet and which Council will
bear the costs and how would it be
apportioned
take it back
and I can simply answer the first one
with no we don't know what the scale of
that is we haven't been through service
reviews how it's going to be
proportioned it's been identified that
the starting point is going to be a 50
50 split on those costs
okay
any other members indicating
council Mrs Gadsden got a question I
would just like to pass on my
congratulations to the officers that
took part and raised I think was 12 000
pounds in the free Peaks Challenge and I
think the whole committee would like to
congratulate them on their work and the
charity efforts and and members
thank you no one else is indicating I've
just got a couple of questions if I may
um the first one that relates to
paragraph 7.1 in the report and we
haven't spent all of the budget as
planned
um
and
my question is if we haven't spent the
budget are we behind on something
no no no we're not behind it is where it
should be and we're planning obviously
there's another six months left
seven months left of the calendar year
so we're not behind on anything we're
working through all the scenarios there
is still work to go through for this
year okay lovely thanks and my final
point is um if you've got your
microscopes ready on
um appendix one
which is Page 6.7
the obviously a change of senior
responsible oh no and I just want to
check did you have a formal Handover
when you took over so yeah and actually
actually ongoing with the person that
originally had this so with the original
strategic director which was Angela
Hutchins I had a number of meetings with
her and there is also a consultant
Angela Hogg who I'm also working with
who set some of the governance up so
there has been that formal Handover as
that should be with all the adults that
will go through lovely thank you very
much okay no one else is indicating we
do have one recommendation
um which was to investigate
the use of existing staff to upskill the
new staff
so I'll put that to join me to read that
again
just about doubly sure investigate the
use of existing staff to upskill new
staff and that was
um
all right sorry yeah
sorry to investigate
existing staff can be upskilled for the
outstanding roles
okay okay
members those in favor of that
recommendation
okay thank you that is unanimous
thank you Greg if you want to uh you
sure leave yep you absolutely yeah
sorry
would impact on the budget there'd just
be increasing the training budget for
that would they not
depends how it turns out that they could
be but potentially a saving as well yeah
so I think it could work both ways but
certainly we'll investigate it
thank you
I hope so chairman
um councilor Milne was making a
recommendation earlier and I don't and
I thought we would probably pause so
that he could give you the
recommendation because I don't see how
his recommendation can be put in later
once the committee's
um closed do you want to make the
recommendation tonight councilman oh yes
yes all it is is that we adopt a smart
process of
um
logging the various issues because this
is a complex multiple work stream
project really and uh
and issues will come up and as we're
going to eventually be reviewing it as
we're
in the scrutiny the end of the minute
otherwise we don't do that then we've
got it's almost like a log of where
we're at and then
we can make use of it later on just make
sure we haven't missed anything that
actually comes back to bias later you
know
so the recommendation is we use the
smart objectives
methodology
because this this is a new committee and
we're looking at how we deal with
scrutiny through to review and that's
all it is really
so can I can I just clarify it so we
adopt a smart objectives methodology
as a for a process to log the issues as
they occur
yeah and and the issues that are
concerns to the councilors and then we
get the responses so we know at a later
date that we've we've dealt with it
because it is because it's complex not
just one simple thing yeah so again can
I can I put words into it so it's logged
them and track them exactly yeah log on
track log and track yeah yeah so we can
use it in review later
okay thanks Council Wilkinson thank you
um as I originally had one question
we've got two now so first of all I
wanted to make sure that is that
feasible would that work before we agree
to something but my second question is
um I may misunderstood uh Bob my
understanding of smart objective is
around that sort of objective so in
other words you are setting Milestones
where you want to achieve as opposed to
dealing with issues now it may be the
smart
the smart environment can be dealt with
for use for lots of different scenarios
I've only ever known it for objectives
rather than dealing with issues so is
that an appropriate use of a smart
objective for this
problem solving approach basically
we've raised something we're worried
about something what's the answer and
that is it really it's a because if you
look at the risk assessment sheet in
part that covers that
um but then members will think of other
things
and later on when we come to review
um
we're just looking at this this work
stream because it's got many different
strings to it it's just to use that just
to log it really I don't know if smart
would be the right term to use really
because I use those you know the boss
one I don't know how far you've got with
something that kind of thing but there's
really to do with the facts that we're
we're covering it later and when we come
to review this which could be a year
away or more we could then say well we
did look at this we did cover that we
did get an answer on this because
there's a lot of things here
and that's it really so so I just I'm
just going to be absolutely clear
because it's going to make a
recommendation so it's about the
logging and tracking of issues and then
when we've got them then we work with
them in a smart way but I accept
councilor Wilkinson's point is that
feasible to set up this login and
tracking system
in in a project management world you
usually do track and log issues and make
sure that you resolve them or what's
happened to them so in that manner yes
we can set up an issues log and make
sure we do track them and we do resolve
them so there is a history of them as we
move forward and we can reflect and
review them as we go forward
thank you and does that answer your
point councilor Wilkinson sorry
feasibility
yes it does
um
I've still got a question mark in my
head around that use them for dealing
with issues because if you if the
suggestion was maybe that that say for
example
um you were looking at an aspect of the
project you said right we want to
achieve this this and this you set up
then smart objectives to achieve this
this and this and they're measurable and
they're you know and everything else
achievable and everything yes my
understanding of what councilman is
saying is that what we're going to do is
we're going to deal with your tracking
of your objectives the way that you're
planning to do it as and when issues
arise that's when the smart objectives
come in which there seems to be sort of
counter-intuitive to me but maybe that's
just me if you think that can work then
I'll I'll defer to your professionalism
in that area no I mean
yeah no I I think the use of smart
against issues may be difficult if I'm
honest but I think it's more the
tracking logging and how we deal with
them and making sure that's very
transparent and everyone can see that is
that absolutely yeah is that okay yeah
that's definitely we can do that
we just had an element of that if there
wasn't a problem and then you know that
would just be part of it
it's not a strict classical
is this does this reflect your
recommendation
to adopt an appropriate methodology to
log and track issues that pose risks for
the council
okay members I'll read that out again to
adopt an appropriate methodology to log
and track issues that pose risks for the
council those members in favor
thank you that's unanimous
please yeah you're free to go now
thank you
okay moving on members to agenda item
seven
um
which
which is the health check review of the
asset delivery program
um before we before I invite counselor
Webb and uh Matt Harbor white to speak
on it what I would say is that this is
quite unusual we didn't commission this
report this report was produced for the
senior responsible owner which is
um about Harbor white so with that in
mind we didn't conduct the review so
what we're not trying to do is second
guess the review but we are to look at
the recommendations that are in the
report and where necessary amplify them
or clarify or make recommendations okay
thank you so who wants to go first
councilor Webb yeah thank you chair so
good evening members um
just going to give you a brief summary
of that report if the report that's okay
so as has been said we agreed to this
report we commissioned it
um I believe we are proactive in doing
so
I feel that it is a balanced report it
points out some good work as well as
making recommendations which are valid I
welcome the opportunity to discuss it
and welcome your views on it
this is the second health check that
we've carried out all the
recommendations from the first report
were implemented it would help with the
microphone
can you hear me now
okay thank you so this is the this is
the second health check that we have
carried out all the recommendations from
the first report were implemented and
they're outlined in appendix c
um and we can be confident that we are
following the correct procedures
um just a few positives to draw your
attention to in section one page six
it states the development of the outline
business case for the ADP had been
progressed in exemplary fashion
the Strategic outline case was issued in
August 2018 and the ABC was approved by
the council's investment board in
January 2019 the full business case was
approved by the council in May 2020 we
followed correct procedure using
exemplary project management principles
and then in section three on page nine
of the report and quite a key section
just to read out to you as well
doing nothing is not an option and many
interviewees and stakeholders recognize
this
the council remains in a position where
it has too much space whilst occupying
an aging portfolio of assets with
Leisure and Community assets that remain
financially unviable
changes because of the covid-19 pandemic
have worsen the current position and
strengthened the case for change
the council aspires to operate in a more
agile manner however this is not
possible in the current facilities
without some form of intervention
and just to go through briefly
um the recommendations if that's okay
okay chair then I'll open it up
in terms of the recommendations raised
um the first one I believe we did engage
stakeholders at the height of kovid
which had obviously limitations to it
and I we do need to re-establish
stakeholder trust
um it was not a per not a perfect
process and we recognized that however
we were hindered in what we could do and
need to progress now page six of the
report outlines what we did which as you
read it there actually was quite a lot
including posting frequently asked
questions on the council's website
hosting virtual one-to-one meetings
placing adverts in the local press
creating a dedicated website and
completing telephone appointments
however despite this the review team
found wide acceptance that because a
great deal of Engagement took place
during the height of covid-19 too much
emphasis was played placed on online
methods with too little in-person
messaging as a result the quality of
stakeholder engagement was severely
compromised and some stakeholders felt
excluded from the consultation process
in effect we were living during a
pandemic and our messages got lost
amongst an awful lot of other messages
that were going out so I do believe we
did what we could during a difficult
period however we also need to rebuild
some of those links
in terms of the second point is there is
a need to recast the vision we have seen
significant changes since the ADP
process began
I don't believe any of these could be
foreseen
but do now need to be considered as part
of this recasting these issues are
primarily the first one because of the
covid-19 pandemic and the council now
aspires to operate in a more agile
manner since covid many employees now
work from home and demands office space
are expected to continue to be low in
the future and certainly previous
assumptions of office occupants you need
to be revise to take this into account
and this is not possible in the current
facilities without some form of
intervention
indeed a large part of the building
portfolio is no longer needed the second
significant change has been the cost of
building work has gone up significantly
on base business manager recently said
to me that raw materials have now
doubled in price
so we are being affected very
specifically by what's been termed the
cost of living crisis I think it's more
than that it's the cost of building
materials that's going to have a
significant impact on us
I think we're worth bearing in mind the
original ADP including the works in the
mill was going to cost us approximately
1.5 million
um the actual construction costs now I'm
guessing I know it would be
substantially higher and then finally
the proposed partnership with Brentwood
by Council will result in economies of
scale greater resilience but again
that's going to act changes to the
program going forward
however this still strengthens the case
for Change and as a report outlined
doing nothing is not an option
in terms of the third point I believe
the partnership panel did have a role
it's only helped in terms of the
planning of the buildings and had a key
recommended key role in making
recommendations to the board and crucial
role in shaping the final designs
um
however as we've done previously we will
reflect on the terms of reference of the
partnership panel and up that group
update that group as needed
terms of 0.4 I'd simply say we don't
want to lose any of our excellent
officers and I'd certainly want to
recognize the fantastic and significant
contribution made by them and to thank
them for that I think we underestimate
the value of officers sometimes and I
certainly want to thank them for all
their hard work
and then finally in point five we do
need time to rebuild the vision whilst
recognizing that doing nothing is not an
option this is not a start again but a
time of pause and reflects
in terms of recasting the vision there
will be discussions that take place with
directors with the chief executive and
fellow Council colleagues and we
certainly look to come back to full
Council by the end of the year with an
updated outline business case which will
then go for a final stop go decision by
full Council and we're certainly working
towards the time frame suggested in the
report which is approximately three
months
so in summary I do agree with the
recommendations I'll take any comments
on board from this group and consider
them and take them forward we do
recognize that things can improve and
the stakeholder engagement being one of
them
and in terms of the vision that does
need to be recasted and remodeled
moving forward to that final stop go
decision at full Council has been
previously agreed so happy to listen to
comments or suggestions on the report no
matter if you run to chip in with
anything
yeah
thank you Council Webber evening members
um excuse me uh councilweb's giving Rory
thorough update and has covered all the
points I was going to make thank you
chairman so I'll uh I think we'll leave
it there thank you
thank you councilor Mrs Gooding
good evening thank you uh councilor Webb
for that review there that was uh
are covered quite well uh just a minor
thing that I was concerned about does
the review take on board the changes for
the Mill Hall and Freight as far as the
the carbon footprint goes with any
refurbishment and environmental changes
that will take place and the policies
will obviously be updated accordingly I
would expect
so as a council we are working towards
being carbon neutral that's an ambition
it's an ambitious Target it's one we're
doing our best to meet and certainly as
the ADP goes forward I don't want to
lose sight of that
can I just come back on that yeah yeah
so
um I would like to make a recommendation
that throughout the asset delivery
program
consideration of impact of our carbon
footprint be given when buying in any
Services
Etc
yep
okay
carbon footprint yeah yeah
thanks Sonia
okay so members the recommendation is
that going forward with the ADP
consideration of the impact of carbon of
our carbon footprint be given when
buying in any Services is that the
recommend okay I'll move that from the
chair sorry
chairman may I
actually buying any servers
and procurement yeah
and procurement of goods yeah yeah are
you happy with that yeah okay
okay so just one more time
going forward with the ADP consideration
of the impact of our carbon footprint be
given when buying in any services or
procurement of goods so I'll move that
from the chair those members in favor
those against
any abstentions
okay so that is carried
thank you members
um councilor Wilkinson thank you sir
um there's a couple of quick questions
if I may the the first set of the point
about the engagement
um I think it's generally accepted the
fact that it was very difficult under
the circumstances to engage with
everybody
um so that's take that those taken on
board I think there is another issue
which shouldn't be lost and hopefully
moving forward that will be remembered
which was also the timing of the
engagement as well
um so hopefully I know the mill Hall's
out of it now thankfully but um
certainly with the rest of the project
would hope that it's obviously public
engagement stakeholder engagement is
done at the appropriate time
um the other thing was I was it's a
little bit a little bit surprised at the
time scale that counts the web has
mentioned about being able to come to
full counts in three months because I'm
very aware of having read the reports
they've quite rightly identified some
huge changes in working practice since
the first IBC was done so it's it's I
was I mean I was talking to Matt about
this before the meeting I'm not
suggesting we're going back to square
one because we're not we all said we
have to move from South Street because
it's not fit for purpose
but we are nowhere near where we were
three years ago how many years ago was
that this ovc was first was first done
so there's a lot of work to do there
um and also there's a lot of concern
um certainly within the members of the
partnership panel the last meeting we
had around the the building costs and
the gap between the Revenue income from
South Street and the building costs for
The Freight House which seemed to be
growing uh exponentially day by day
um so I'm just a little bit a little bit
surprised I should say that you're
looking at three months so is is that
the case or do you think there's um are
you going to be going straight back to
ground zero and starting again or you're
just going to start just returning the
numbers
foreign
really useful question thank you I think
it's a challenge that's a changing time
scale um I'll say it very clearly it is
that's a challenge
um but we need to work out Pace with
this program
um I think uh we're at a point now where
we have a
the report sets out some really
useful challenges to us in terms of
those three cares of the key areas have
flanked inflation departure of Brentwood
and obviously impacts of covid so I
think what the report sets out is it's
not a back to the drawing board approach
it's a review of the principles of the
OBC we've added value to our sites by
securing planning so we've added value
to those sites the questions now around
in terms of The Freight House what does
that look like um do we need to review
that in terms of the principles behind
that
um I think on that base I think it can
be achieved slightly challenging
um so I think it's a review of the the
principles rather than the entire
strategic case the Strategic case for
change has been strengthened I think the
report says that I think that's where it
sets out so
that case is there to achieve a form of
the ADP is what it finally looks like I
think is a challenge but I think on
principal terms I think it's achievable
but yeah it will be challenging
just come back chair for me yeah thank
you
um forgive me my lack of knowledge here
um does the outline business case will
that include costings or is that the
financial business case that comes
afterwards because I'm just I'm just
concerned that's where my concern lies
actually is not the principle of what
we're trying to achieve it I think we
will agree and agree with you I think
this case is strengthened it is the
costings of The Freight House that gives
me great concerns which is why I was
surprised with the time scale you
mentioned so is that going to be
included in that or is that a completely
different piece of work
so the OBC would give you would give you
indicative figures
um the key bit of the OBC would be to
review those strategic drivers of the
case for change and then if the figures
change as a result of that we highlight
those but it would need yes an FBC a
final business case to retell as well
but that can be a an FPC can be
relatively light touch all we're doing
is confirming any movement in the
numbers from the ovc to the FBC because
the face of working out that could be
relatively straightforward but it is the
it's the case for change we need to
consider and the principles behind that
that's the key piece of work to do next
thank you
um Council Mr Newport
thank you chairman um
sorry Matt you just refresh me on this
because I thought there was a stop go
point in October
am I incorrect
we haven't there is a stop go decision
to be taken yeah we haven't set a date
we didn't have a date okay no so you you
mentioned earlier that
um obviously doing this at ovc and and
um you know building costs and all of
that but how do you take into account
the danger sat behind uh the doors of
number 10 and the cuts to public
finances and cuts possibly to our budget
as a whole with that come in at the OBC
or would that come in
um
later on because we could find ourselves
in with a huge budget deficit
or budget Gap I I think
so I think it that goes back to the case
for change I think uh their
our risks to any programs any
development programs I think we're also
would review the risks of not doing it
in terms of the case for change the
program has brought forward because
there were an opportunity to regenerate
some of our spaces but also deliver
Financial efficiencies so that was the
one of the key drivers it was around
those efficiencies so that's part of the
case for change so to Leading the
project and that Still Remains we'll
have to review those efficiencies in
light of uh the building cost now uh but
also the opportunity savings
um in terms of the cost of operating our
current estate which is report sets out
it's too large some Surplus assets the
opportunity is there to still deliver
those savings across those buildings
could I uh sort of help out a bit
because I put the experience of this
sort of thing
we it's not possible for the council to
second guess what
the treasury mail may not do so in
effect what we have to do is March to
the latest order what we know as of
today so we would make our plans I hope
I'm not putting words into it but we
would make our plans on what we know
today and if at some time in the future
the budget gets slashed then that would
be affected it would be reflected in the
business case
yeah that's correct it's always a point
in time but I think the point I make is
we enter into this because we were
delivering efficiencies and savings for
the council and for the taxpayer so that
Still Remains the case the any new OBC
and FBC would have to reconsider those
numbers but the case for doing a program
right back at the start was we have
Surplus assets we can regenerate our
spaces and deliver savings and that
Still Remains the case today
and again I don't want to put words into
councilor Mr newport's mouth but you are
you alluding to affordability I think
that yeah we've got the money today yeah
and I think we can't I don't think we
can second-guess that
but it would be reflected in the
business case
yeah does that make sense
okay thank you uh councilor Reeves
reading through the uh report
um I was um
I agree with all the conclusions and
that I think the the one thing I would
point out is my utter frustration
um
reference on the recommendation
recommendation to
back in 2019 when we had the very last
investment board meeting
I brought
the
news from
the industry at Point
to say that a big office programs are
being paused because
they are aware that there is going to be
a change in working practices as a
result of what was happening with kovid
if you remember that last meeting was
the very last meeting that Council had
face to face because kovid had actually
hit us at that particular point in time
um
now
my my frustration from that is basically
because I brought something which was
not my own opinion
it was something that came from the
trade
straight from the point uh very high up
in the trade
and it wasn't even given the time to
discuss
um and I don't even think it's actually
been noted in the minutes
we would have saved ourselves an
absolute Fortune as a council if that
information had been at least looked
into at the time so what I'd like to
actually say just as a conclusion is to
say that if we do get any
information which comes from the trade
in this going forward that we do
actually investigate it going forward
rather than just a gloss over it and
um basically take no notice of it uh
it's it's just from my point of view
it's just a matter of frustration but I
do see that the recommendations in here
I go totally with them thank you
so and I do wonder is there a Lessons
Learned log that we've got
ongoing
yeah there's certainly a risk register
as you'd imagine uh with key risks
identified
um that's actually one of the
recommendations to more regularly review
that risk register
and so that's being refreshed as we
speak and certainly lessons I learned
and collated from that risk register for
health chin
so yeah cancer Mrs McPherson
thank you chairman it's really just
coming on the back of our councilory's
um mentioned is that included and can we
see that risk register perhaps here at
overview in scrutiny if fellow members
would like to see that
German very happy to share that it's
been reported to members on previous
occasions through various ADP updates
we're happy to share that again
thank you Mr chairman
um whilst I understand
um a lot of the other counselors
reservations about rushing into things
the longer this
evaluation takes
to complete the higher our costs will be
in maintaining the existing buildings
the higher the build costs are going to
be so I fully agreed that three months
is a good time scale to come back to and
obviously if it takes longer then then
they can come back to us and say yes we
need a bit more time but to have a
three-month time scale is quite a good
thing because it Focus people's minds
and you know that's going to be towards
the winter period And there's a cost of
heating all those buildings and looking
after and maintaining them until such a
time we hand them over to the builders
yeah
thank you thanks
any other point
okay can I ask a question because I've
got a
um
particularly it refers to the
recommendations two and four
um and I've got a lot of experience in
projects I've never seen a project with
such a massive change things like covid
and inflation running away so those are
all things that you you couldn't
reasonably predict
um but what I want to do is amplify the
the recommendation really is that and it
picks up on something that councilor
Wilkinson said will we be resetting the
Baseline back to zero in other words
where we are today
so and
will we be looking at
options that may have been discarded in
the past but actually might now be
relevant what I don't want to do is I
don't want the past to necessarily
influence the future Solutions you might
come up with
we've got a chance now to pause and
reflect
um previous things that have been looked
at and discounted we can look at again
in terms of the time frame maybe three
months isn't quite realistic but I don't
want this to be hanging around in 12 24
months time we've got pressing need to
do something with our Workforce and I
think the plan is very clear on that so
it's not a case of starting again but it
is a case of building on what's on gone
before but recasting that Vision into
maybe something that's slightly
different
okay thank you
God so I've actually got the
recommendation that I I'd like to move
from the chair and it's at the executive
ensure that the program
continues to be vision-led and that all
options will be evaluated uh regardless
of whether they were part of the
original business case
that
sound okay
okay members I'll read it out again
sorry
so I've got that thank you yeah so it's
the recommendation that the executive
ensure that the program continues to be
vision-led and that all options will be
evaluated regardless of whether they
were part of the original on business
case
so in other words if there was something
that wasn't appropriate when we looked
at the original that might be
appropriate now or something that we
thought was appropriate but isn't now
it's to make sure
we're not being Guided by history as it
were understood thank you chair thank
you for clarifying uh my concern with
that would be that sounds more like a
what you call a strategic outline case
so that is going right back to the
beginning looking at the long list of
options which could include things we
have discussed in the past and discarded
what the report's talking about is a
recast of the OBC so the principles in
that OBC are ways of working impact of
covid the impact of inflation uh the
impact of the partnership and the
opportunity of the partnership rather
than going back to basis of a long list
that would certainly take longer it can
be done but it will be that long if
you've got you're going back to You're
Going Back to Basics and strategic
principles at that point yeah I
understand what you're saying all I was
thinking was that some things that you
might have discarded you could just say
they're still no longer
but I wouldn't expect it to be a lot of
a lot of work it would still be at a
very high level
and I don't know what those I don't know
what those options are so I'm not trying
to second guess them it's just to make
sure that we don't we don't discount
something now that we thought was no
good but actually might be useful and
vice versa
can you slightly done uh and we can
review
um a strategic outlying case as part of
that work
um
it just may require a bit longer a bit
more engagement more happy to take that
away I think it can be done absolutely
happy with that okay thanks so I'll read
that out again and then I'll move it
from the chair so the recommendation is
that the executive ensure that the
program continues to be vision-led and
that all options will be evaluated
regardless of whether they were part of
the original outline business case
those in favor
those against
any abstentions
okay that is carried by majority
okay and we've got one other
recommendation uh from council Mrs
McPherson
thank you sorry committee we didn't
actually um vote on this so the
recommendation following on from the
conversation with councilories the
recommendation that the risk register or
Lessons Learned to log is presented to
this committee
of those in favor
that is unanimous thank you members
thank you councilor Webb councilor yes
sir councilor why if you want to go
you're welcome to today find out
thank you chair thank you
yeah sorry uh Matt you might have to
stay a little bit longer
um I saw something in here about
tensions between the ADP partnership and
uh and GB partnership uh can you enlarge
on that and have they been resolved
thank you Chet thank you chair um the
tensions related to the planning process
in terms of some of our statutory
consulties and the process that GB went
through to achieve planning for the
disposal sites it was a tough process as
it should be with the LPA a robust
process all the sites are cheap planning
but it was a tough process as we went
through high engagement high level of
scrutiny as it should be for a council
disposed site in a conservation area of
listed buildings but it was a changing
process
okay okay thanks and finally we've got
two recommendations on the report that
the health check review of the asset
delivery program recommendations uh
contain
therein so we've we've noted those
okay
and then that the committee makes any
recommendations to the executive for
consideration and we've taken those and
voted on those as well okay thank you
yeah
moving on to item eight before I do this
I'd like to thank councilor Milne and
Council Reeves for their work
on producing this report for the
committee so I would like whoever you
can do it as a double act or you can do
it if you've got a spokesman but would
you give us an overview of the report
please
you know with uh
no is that is that better yeah that's
good
uh yeah
um I have to say it's two rdc's uh
credit actually that when we looked into
writing this report that they've
embraced the statutory guidance and
overview of scrutiny as laid out by the
ministry of Housing and local government
and Angela Hutchins
took the steps of
um inviting the center for governance
and security security to carry out an
evaluation
and they they produced in their final
letter a number of recommendations and
I've listed these in section one
um but the gist of it is it's a refresh
of the Review Committee
providing Clarity of scrutinies
functions and it enables us to engage
more fully on policy and key decisions
uh in in a constructive framework it is
challenging as well
so and and also gets us a better
engagement with the executive and better
preparation for these meetings because
there are pre-meetings that are arranged
that outline
um what what the issues are and we've
got classic examples with questions
tonight which has been passed around
um so that
side of it and the investment by RDC in
training has been quite quite
significant so we'd like to thank
the realityc and the executive are
actually supplying that for us
um what we are on is of course a
learning curve and this is where we look
at the progress of the committee since
we were formed and the title was changed
uh we have
um
responded to to the to the uh the
methodology of scrutiny and uh and and
overview
um
but um we've also now learned through a
list of various work streams we've had
in our work program that we can join an
existing issue such as treasury
management and science it's always
ongoing we look at where we're at and we
join in and look at that position and
then we're then in a position to review
that later on but we've also got
completely brand new
strategies like the litter strategies
we're able to look at that as it's
planned and then we're able to now
review that later on when we've seen how
it's gone through so and the one team
transformation program and tonight we've
seen an example I think it's a big
advantage and Advance on
um the the uh the Review Committee
process and I'd like to thank uh
councilor Eaves uh because
um
it is a cross-party report and we're a
cross-party committee so from that point
of view
um all of that is good so at the moment
um
in the conclusion of the report we have
responded to overview and scrutiny
guidance from the ministry of housing
um and local government we've invested
in training we are engaging and actually
developing processes the way we deal
with things and we have got a better
engagement with the executive there's no
doubt about that and the officers and uh
I like thank you Mr chairman because uh
you're quite a good organizer I have to
sell you
and I'd like to thank Angela Hutchins
who actually got the ball rolling here
as well um
I understand she's moved on or has she
moved yeah she has moved on now yeah
yeah anyway that's that's it really it
is a joint report just says where we're
at and uh
you know and we are covering all of the
issues in the recommendations from from
the the report to Angela commissioned
okay thank you once again thank you to
both of you for doing it
for volunteering which is uh
[Laughter]
okay members has anyone got any
questions for councilor Milton or
Council Reeves
okay
um so members is the report noted
thank you
uh we move on to item nine which is the
key decisions document
um and if we look at the key decisions
document there are
three that have been announced today
three key decisions that have been
been published so we've got on page two
of the report the environmental health
service plan
and we've got the
sorry
yeah the modern slavery act will be done
later
it's been done earlier sorry yep and
then we've got the car parking which is
always a favorite which was announced
today and then the final one that we'll
have on the list for the next meeting
will be the voluntary sector Grant
allocations so those are out there if
anyone's needs to call them in or feels
they need to call in any of those
decisions you've got to let me know
within three days I think it is
five
there you are inflation
any questions on the key decision
document members
okay thank you
um moving on to the final item which is
our work plan
um and before say too much well before
we go through it in detail those of you
that attended the training that was
given
um last month
will remember that the work plan is a
living document so it's not it's not
tying Us in stone so items can come in
and out of the the plan and we can amend
the sequence of what goes on and one
thing I would ask is that if members
wish to bring an item on to the plan and
it requires a member working group that
that you if you're not going to do it
yourself that you've got someone lined
up to do it because it's actually quite
difficult to get volunteers
um to do some of the work and I
understand people are busy but if we're
bringing work on there is also a
resource implication for us
councilor Newport your indicating do you
want to speak before we go through the
plan or
um yeah and only to um thank chairman
just to remind you of the request to um
add an additional item on Gypsy and
travelers
policy and position
and um
the application of evidence and policy
yep
yep and I agree with that have you will
you be able to supply any resources for
that
in terms of sorry helping to look at the
Gypsy and Traveler
how do you envisage it working do you
visit a report from officers yeah a
report from the officer okay yeah that's
what you need yeah sorry I thought you
meant that no a report from Phil drain
yeah I think is uh appropriate thanks
okay yeah thank you
thank you council Mrs McPherson
um it's just a question through you
chair to council Mr Newport
um councilor Mr Wilkinson and Mick
Wilkinson and myself are just um
put some questions to
officers on enforcement so that we can
then start to have a background to ask
them to bring something forward here if
necessary is it worth you putting some
questions to the officer first around
the policy
it's only a thought the officers had
many questions already that are
unanswered so we just need the report
from the officer and I think the officer
is expecting to produce that report on
Gypsy and travelers anyway already okay
thank you thank you okay thank you
no one else has indicated so we'll go
through the plan then
um
and we'll we'll look forward so the
seventh of November
um we've got the Ripper
um
coming up especially for cancer
Constable the uh the review of the
Regulatory and investigatory Powers Act
and that's statutory so we have to
review that whether we like it or not
um we've got the
um
I put we've got this as a provisional
which is a report of the task and finish
group on the review of the terms of
reference of the flood Forum
um and I've got some volunteers who are
prepared to undertake that work and I
I'm hoping without
well without being Hostage to Fortune
that's going to be a relatively
straightforward piece of work which is
reviewing the the documentation and then
making recommendations where necessary
in December we've got the treasury
management
mid-year review again which is statutory
um and then I'm looking to the vice
chair and councilor Wilkinson who are
undertaking this work we've got a report
on the task and finish group of planning
enforcement is does that look achievable
run on time for that brilliant okay
thank you
yeah
um are you expecting or would you like a
report similar to the one that
councilman councilor Reeves did yes
please yeah okay yeah
if yeah if you ask member services
they'll be able to support uh let's get
it in the in top 10 Town
um January we've got the update we've
asked for an update from the portfolio
holder for climate and economy on the
carbon neutral 2030.
and then there is a task and finish
Group which
I've volunteered to lead
on planning processes and procedures so
I'm pretty confident that we can we can
meet that date because to kick it off
I've got a meeting with Phil vane on
next week or the week after so that
should be okay
first of February you've got the
treasury management strategy that's the
annual investment strategy and minimum
Revenue provision policy statement which
I guess in the current climate will
probably be quite interesting
um we've been asked by a member to have
an update on the South Essex
parking partnership
um this has come out there's been
concerns with residents about parking
Etc so what we thought was having
learned from the the training that we
can call these people in we'll get them
in and we'll we'll run through with them
so they are
booked for that date I believe they're
confirmed
um and first of March we've got the
community safety partnership and again
this is something that we do annually
but if those of you that were here last
year will recall that we got the Chief
Inspector in and
poor lady got a real grilling but
actually the community safety
partnership is much more than that so
what we're looking to do is get other
agencies in as well it's not it's not
just um
it's not just an action on the police
and then the 4th of April we've got the
annual report
Council Mr Newport chairman as a part of
the community safety partnership
um review and you were just saying about
you know we get the local policing team
inspectorate yeah I think it might be um
prudent to bring in the police fire
crime commissioner as well for that if
we can get him in because um I think
there's a lot of issues that we we face
that you know we'd like to uh speak to
him about as well yes I think the um
there's nothing wrong with us asking for
that so yeah I'll take that as an action
to request the police and crime
commissioner to attend
which I think would be useful well he's
also the fire brigade yes yeah
okay thanks
councilor Mrs McPherson
I'm not um opposed to the pfcc being
asked to come to that meeting but don't
forget his role is strategic it would be
better as if I feel to have
representation from the fire service and
the police individually as they're both
statutory members of the CSP but perhaps
the pfcc can come back and
tell us health is also and also
probation members of the CSP along with
obviously ourselves
I know in previous years we've
questioned The Joint partnership as well
and issues around that
thanks councilor Wilkinson oh I'm
certainly don't want to come back and
contradict councilman person at all
because she's exactly right it is more
strategic however what I would say is
that they are very much led by the
direction of the pfcc when it comes to
priorities
and I think we've had we had Kathy
Calder here last year with inspector
who's talked about her you know her
ability or inability other at times to
be able to prioritize certain things
that comes from the top yeah um so you
know we're asking the wrong person in
the center really but I do take a point
that you know they are statutory people
but I I would agree with what council
Newport says in relation to the previous
season
I don't think there's any harm in asking
if he's available
you know any wishes to come down you can
do
um we've got some items that are
scheduled for for this year
um we've got the review of The
Constitution which is ongoing
um and then there's one that's come up
from the previous year members that were
on the committee last year remember that
we had a a member's task and finish
Group which was reporting on the
management of public open spaces and if
you'll recall though the report was
given verbally and so there was a
recommendation made which was lost but
I've been approached by a member to say
well rather than lose this work can we
bring it back in and have it as a
written report so I've asked councilman
Mrs Mason who was the
um leading the work if she can contact
member services so they can format in
the right format and then we can we can
re-revote on the recommendations so we
don't lose that
so that concludes oh sorry
because Mrs Gooding
um health update we we have funding
um that is reinfenced for our health and
NHS and I wonder if it would be
appropriate perhaps to uh to approach
them to come in we have had ccg in the
past and obviously they the names move
on but the bodies stay the same
yeah so we're so we've just been looking
for an update from them and where yeah
okay if we can take that as an action
please to contact
uh ccg2 bring them in yeah
what is it like okay
no other members are indicating so that
is the final item of business
um
yes or before I actually closed the
meeting we've got a training session
next Monday
so but I know if you can attend I
appreciate people's Diaries
you may not be able to attend but the
training that we've had from these
people is really good it's really worth
getting to if you can
um I mean I think just a straw poll
members that attended did you find it
useful last time
yeah so if you can attend I strongly
urge you to so thank you
oh cancer Newport do you think it may be
possible because
um I've got another meeting to attend
but that we could get even an audio
recording of the training session and
the slides to go with it because
it does follow on from the last session
which was it was worthwhile yeah we
should be able to yeah I mean even if we
can only eat rewind
I think the focus would be on the
trainer trainers got to say and if if we
can we'll get members questions in as
well yeah sorry and councilor Wilkinson
the
um training session last time when I
spoke to yeah that whether you know we
should all have a bit of a get together
at some time whether we had a I mean I
know a work plan is quite full but there
was so much useful information and
there's so much to digest I think it
would be worth all sitting down and just
discussing it rather than just bomb
bursting and never talking about it
again so I don't know what you know what
we can do and I agree and it's not that
I didn't try and do it no I didn't
ignore you the Majesty the queen
died and so everything was then
put on hold so I hadn't forgotten about
it what I actually wanted to do was
because the other training would have we
would have done both sets of training in
short order and then had the meters I
think it was a really good thing to do I
absolutely agree
um because
speaking to members in the margins
afterwards and so what about this what
about that you know I spoke to council
Newport have we thought about doing that
you know same with cancer Mrs McPherson
so yes I think that would be a really
good thing if people can attend
thank you chairman uh just on the back
of what councilor um Mike Wilkinson just
mentioned and perhaps we could also look
at some succession planning because the
this committee changes from year to year
some of us have been on here for years
some haven't but it would be good to
have some sort of
um substance to the committee moving
forward
um that we can keep there with when
we've gained all this training thank you
okay I'll take an action to write to to
group leaders just to float that as an
idea I can't I can't mandate him I can
float the idea okay okay so that
concludes the business
sorry my apologies
um Mr chair just a point of
clarification
um are they likely or is it intended to
have any pre-meetings to this future
work program
yes well for each one
yeah so what what we do is before
before each meeting
um
we schedule a zoom call or a team's
meeting and the idea is that people get
together we look at the areas of concern
and and make sure that we're not
doubling up on any questions that we may
have and in advance perhaps come up with
think of potential recommendations as
well but we do you should get did you
get it I didn't oh right I'm sorry uh
chair through
You full member right then yes you
should have been on the on the zoom I
don't think I was invited but when that
is one point for me
invite to the queen me
to raise
cancer Roots yep
thank you just a small Point um
following on from Council Newports
issues about Diary
I did say I was coming but unfortunately
it clashed with planning training
and so I mean it's one of those sort of
things I would really implore officers
to when they're booking these things to
look at their Diaries and try not to
overlap yeah In fairness and
we because of the schedule of when this
meeting takes place we try and do it the
week before and there was there were a
number of clashes and to be fair to
Sonia she did identify that and so what
we ended up doing was taking the
decision the one that
affected at least the least number of
people as it were because people had
different
meetings with different committees and
that sort of thing so there's never
going to be a perfect solution to this
and all I would say if
you've got any issues or observations or
recommendations mate you can always give
me a call or or drop me an email because
then I can start forwarding those on
um but yeah we it's not that we don't
want people there it's unfortunately
sometimes it's yeah
the other thing is that
um when her majesty passed away
meetings had to be rescheduled as well
so that was another fly in the ointment
so yeah we are trying our best it's not
that we don't want you there Adrian
right thank you members so that's the
final
um piece of business so the meeting is
finished at 2050.
thank you very much